what's up party people welcome to the
Amish trailer commentary for Thor
Ragnarok we'll be talking about the
video you hopefully just watched over on
screen duckies main if you stick around
at the end of this one you'll see the
deleted scenes that weren't good enough
to make it into the honest trailer we
like the movie spoiler alert let's talk
about it Joe Star Dan Merle hi it's a
good movie yeah I was sick I was talking
about it earlier it's it's weird when
people ask us like what are the two
hardest honest trailers to write we
always say good movies and comedies hmm
dominate both yeah yeah there's a comedy
saying like don't put a hat on a hat if
there's a joke you don't need to make a
joke on top of that joke this movie
would one big joke are you gonna do
you're not gonna make jokes out of the
jokes no it's already got a head on you
don't need doesn't have a hat yeah but
we tried or talked about other things
but yeah this was just like a delightful
comedy mediocre action with it not me
good action good a really good comedy
and I mean I know it's like trite but
like the Marvel movies are fun and this
was a really fun one yeah yeah this is
no option for us to not do it yeah well
you know because everyone saw it and
good for good for everyone for showing
up for the third Thor movies because it
was like so weird it doesn't on the
surface sound good at all like a comedy
Thor
sequel buddy movie yeah but it was great
yeah like 'full it was a delight it was
fun yeah lots of colors noises noises
best Led Zeppelin drop the in film I'd
wager one of my favorites better than
the Godzilla one yeah and like Thor is
goofy so they embraced yes way better
than P Diddy and Jimmy Page just come
with me yeah thank you
[Music]
immigrant song is my favorite Led
Zeppelin song oh well then you love
PPD's verses on top of it no yeah well
no I wish Puff Daddy would wrap over
immigrant song no you know I think you
don't you think you do you don't Joe
that's the biggest tragedy of losing
notorious b.i.g is that and and make
jokes on top of the jokes on top of the
jokes yes this is a triple head of that
situation
from Marvel Studios I like this dan you
partner yeah those still going really
long all right really long it did get me
pretty hyped you know going the first
time I saw it yeah
alright here comes this is the free
because since so much about Marvel
movies it's like just cut it off nobody
has time for that
right now we're running behind its Thor
Thor Ragnarok after the dark world
Marvel is back with a radical new
formula for the Thor Cho defends the
dark brows I'm making them suck
[Applause]
can we it's not I agree it's not
terrible but let's just go yeah okay we
just go from that shot that to shot to
shot like movie to movie they're like
what's the difference between these two
movies that's one oh that's that I mean
the person's real Snyder II first well
first ones like very stately beretta
it's like a cheese curry
that's filter and that's a poppy very
poppy this is very brightly lit yes
there's some green screen moments in
this this is that something you point on
in Austria however there are some
green-screen moments this movie I'm like
come on
mmm like the whole field when they're
out there with Helen Odin oh it's like
you couldn't go to a physio literally a
field with nothing behind it and there
were obviously not in a field yeah so
situation it is yeah just go to a field
this alley looks just like that alley I
know where the Disney studio is there's
a field like right next to there right
but they had to shoot I don't know do
you think they like captured a field in
Norway and then yes yes which always
this is always an underrated thing about
these movies and the mythology they've
established is that the ancient Norse
people were worshipping aliens like they
were they were like more onto the truth
than yeah any other religion unless
there's like a Jesus and Moses planet
and they're also like I think that's a a
they throw effectively but yet like the
Norse the the Vikings were right that
they note they totally nail that really
needs to be in Thor like the ancient
aliens guys
to be in the movie yeah yeah go figure
let's keep watching I'll defend dark
rolled on my Twitter suck in an
installment that trims all the dead
weight off the franchise from his love
interest sorry to hear that Jane come to
to his homeland to his friend you
couldn't name with a gun to your head to
his right eye to his dad his hair and
even his hammer
they just trimmed all the weight off huh
it's like the whole franchise got on
Hemsworth steamed chicken diet I mean I
didn't miss any of what they got rid of
I wasn't like Vince name the Warriors 3
right now got lady SIF and the other
ones
lady SIF does that count the worst three
Gimli yep Robin Hood Chuck yeah he got
recast a couple times yeah yeah I think
one and the other one one of his name is
yodel I think that's that's yodel oh one
of these guys is yogurt yo oh yeah that
fondue yondu no fine think what it's fun
I do know you're making that up
fondue we're cheddar fun drill financial
Fandral but which one is he or is that
like a fan Jill is Gimli okay
no Fandral is a decongestant andrel oh
no fangirls a decongestant expectorant
is what i mean this part of me this is
like it is kind of a cheap thing to do
just to be like yeah I don't care
kind of cheapens the other two Oh like
it's very easy to just be like whatever
well because in the first two movies
they were just whatever like they
werethe or ends that showed up and got
knocked out so the Thor could say I get
it the storytelling purist and my heart
was a little like he's JA CG a little
too much yeah it's just like it's lazy
but if I get it it's like there's I get
that you were in a narrative
I get that you're in a narrative dead
end with the Thor movies but at the same
time I'm not saying it was the wrong
move I think objectively for the series
it was the right move the storytelling
Pierson in my heart was like that's
cheap it could have
handled with a little more gravitas but
for me it was a feeling of relief never
once does it cut away from us so
basically people long story short
expectorant is dead
yeah like a taps anyways keep going
continue meet the war god of thunder who
despite being able to shoot lightning
from his hands spends most of the film
getting electrocuted
I know it's alien technology but he's
very clearly being taste when Thor's
father Luke Skywalker's himself into the
afterlife same Sita goddess of pointy
things will return to claim the throne
hiding all those spikes family feud that
will make you wonder are we sure Thor
wasn't adopted one put him next to hella
Loki and young Anthony Hopkins and tell
me he's not the odd got out thrill as
indie comedy director Tycho YTD takes
the reins of a giant superhero movie
because when you're part of a 14 billion
dollar global franchise ytf nod now it's
out with the old and in with the jokes
behold
watch the nose Tech oh I didn't see it
there what why would he keep his stuff
in the because he has to watch you know
he's an immortal I guess keep his stuff
well Heimdall respected the position
yeah and and but yeah I figured that
like that's where you have to that's
your office it's like why do you have so
many toys I'm just pen sorry Joe so many
things on your desk that's guys I'm lazy
that's sloppy
well because I just keep everything
because I'm like I need to look at
everything I've ever touched hold your
stuff yeah now in my defense my stuff is
arranged really well mmm
mine is not and neither is scourge Asst
right yeah Spencer's desk is like
Cameron's dad's house from Ferris
Bueller it's cold and you know there's
only two things yeah yeah exactly a
computer and the audacity for you behold
my stuff it's a laptop that's it alright
let's keep watching my stuff we're
boring exposition scenes get tagged by
jokes
I will tell
over the mountains and very Mysore
deepen as well give it a second
badass moments get tagged by jokes you
wanted to know who I am
even today one too many times stabbed by
jokes
yeah they overdo it sometimes but this
is a movie where an orgy spaceship
shoots fireworks over the Rainbow Bridge
where Hulk fights a zombie wolf if
you're mad at tries to make you laugh -
you're doing it wrong
follows a car a collection I guess I'm
kind of doing it you're kind of doing
like 20 percent but taking it a little
too much too much to heart too much for
me
I agree well that's was that was the
point of the run was saying that you
know they overdo it yeah they do maybe
three too many tags we like okay we we
can have one moment where like the
feeling just sits with you until you you
know you're gonna laugh I'll give you as
guard blowing up I don't need to be I
don't need everything diffuse you didn't
need everything it was there were taiko
T's a comedy director they were making a
comedy mm-hmm but yet they could have
respected the the the reality of a few
moments more yes I like the movie I'll
give you as guard I won't give you piss
off ghosts because that is the soft
ghost
I like the softest we to be fair Asgard
was in this cut but it's so long yeah
that's a long set up it's like you got
to keep these things snappy yeah we ever
sitting on the Marvel logo for 30
seconds to make up somewhere come on
gotta go yeah laughs once in a while
don't take it too seriously life says
yeah life's a gas alright let's keep
going follow Thor's exile and sack are a
collection of the galaxy's most colorful
gladiators garbage and gold booze who's
gonna get in first and thrill as it
turns into the closest thing we'll get
to a Planet Hulk movie where Bruce
Banner awakens to find he spent the last
two years of his life as an enslaved
killing machine hawk for two years the
hell happened and take all of nine
minutes to get over it
you on revenge
and as undecided together they'll team
up with new additions to the thorn
averse like the depressive alcoholic
valkyrie thanks a Taika Waititi made of
rocks durable ruffled lincoln and a mute
bug with nice forearms and they still
have more personality than the Warriors
3 turning that bullet lady SIF but don't
worry you still got a common plus in I
think that's the solve for Thor's like
he's boring as the character so make him
kind of a goofy barbarian and surround
him with a bunch of freaks yeah I'm the
same with the Hulk like he I know in the
comics he's done it many times but in
the movies he only seems to play well
with others
yeah he's a supporting I need someone to
play against him and same with I think
that's the the winning come though sort
of winning formula for Thor and if they
I know they're gonna do a masters of the
universe movie apparently and if they
take it seriously it's going to be the
stupidest stupidest movie yes yeah oh my
god what a weird ass movie that is yeah
we do one for Masters of the Universe
I'm better we will it turned 30 last
year I think we think we well whatever I
guess no one noticed let's tell them
we're doing the last Jedi yes and then
we're just gonna do Hawk shine guys if
you're watching don't tell anyone
yeah act surprised okay let's watch
enjoy the first Marvel film where
everything actually looks like a classic
Marvel comic book that reminds us all
Thor's a cosmic Viking created by nerds
on acid in the 60s it should look crazy
with the best bridge sequence it's
Deadpool
the best humane laser fights in starship
troopers and the best vehicle chase
sequence where the hero jumps out to
take the bad guys down by hand since all
the other ones now in every this is one
of you we found Marvel's new sky beam
yay so get pumped for what's easily the
best Thor movie also the best Hulk movie
probably the best Doctor Strange movie
the second best Guardians movie and
shoot probably the best he-man movie
we're ever gonna get to then hopefully
talk Marvel an important lesson don't
fire the weirdo embrace him embrace that
weirdo stuff I mean he seems delightful
right he's like because yes hilarious I
wish him nothing but success and it does
make me wonder / wish why ant-man wasn't
weirder did they did they evolve their
perspective or Aztecas just like better
at playing by the rules
I think ant-man came at a time when
probably Marvel was very concerned with
maintaining the Canon mm-hmm and now
they are less upholding the brand and
was so such a standalone like it didn't
really touch on anything else in the MCU
and it was a comedy was hilarious
yeah but I think when the ocean liner
gets set in its ways enough you know
it's gonna go it's not a it's very nerds
are all very important to the MCU canon
it has to be ABC and then the credits
roll and everyone's very happy yeah and
I think to his credit Feige ahead of
time sees sort of the sea change and
it's like okay I have a feeling that
we're gonna get to this point in people
are gonna start mmm what's an ant-man
right after age of Ultron yes right yeah
because an age of Ultron was the height
of the Marvel like we are building an
intricately interconnected series of
very complex films and then I think
after age of Ultron they're like you
know we're not but it was - we're not
gonna do that but then it was too late
cause ant-man was already and you know
there you go that's my theory they I
think because I like ant-man I think I
like more than most just so that was a
really solid comedy movie and that's
really the only place we get comedies
anymore is if you put a superhero in it
yeah or or it's the usual like not like
game nights a bad example
but yeah but like Thor Ragnarok roughly
these are movies that like buddy buddy
comedies like these are movies that we
used to get without them being
superheroes yeah this is the only way
it's gonna happen you know is if you get
a Squirrel Girl rom-com yeah which I'd
watch you know yeah yeah I think Kevin
Feige if he had one tick back I'd
probably be to do the Edgar cut I know
of a man right we got baby drive around
and we got baby driver yeah I'll take it
let's go well tiger why take it re happy
thought I'd give I am lorde yayaya
actual Jeff Goldblum for the Horde Ben
Tim someone get this woman an untitled
standalone movie Heimdall the time they
were able to get Idris Elba for she's so
thorny george RR martin sure
contractually locked into a cameo sore
AG the current state of the DC EU that's
garbage
should it be Satan and Thor they love
the experience coming summer 2022
Disney's California Adventure flash
Thornton oh look at these lies
note to self before commissioning a
propaganda mural depicting my peaceful
rise to power
don't Commission another mural depicting
the horrible horrible truth why won't
you turn that I wouldn't you erase it
off that original mural scrub daddy and
you don't need to keep the horrible
truth mural up yeah plus it seems like
that ceiling was perilously close to
crushing people for eons yeah yeah yeah
I mean it just took a couple little
Sharpie things that you threw up there
it's like right throw a pencil up there
then prison at the end of war for the
plant the Apes
we had ever done the honest trailer for
that was like my big great movies made
of explosives and like the ground like
Apes for like reaching their arm like up
above like this they would just collapse
it was a very thing it was a very karst
region car street that means it's lots
of caves well okay yeah that's the one
thing I learned in Kentucky public
schools any chance I get to play the
karst card do it Hearst karst region
yeah now that I'm saying it I'm not even
sure that's the right word Hill graphics
on a barbarian raided dead panda Navy in
Jack Burton
Vladislav Snape hair not the best part
of a Thor movie for once El Jefe Jeff go
boom and the mildred Schnitzer oldest
man Jeff's gopu to Ratan are you not
been attained Tila Thompson elbow gourd
pole at Rio nice rag her helmet Twisted
Sister premier executioner dread call
norc's axle blows US gun control policy
you're a wizard Steven there's something
strange in your neighborhood
the power of jump cuts take a seat
stop hammer time Ruffalo Ruffalo run
Liam Neeson run both owes a lot to the
Julliard Max Fisher players respond to
ball rod that's so metal as guardians of
the galaxy super smash bros The Revenge
errs calls themselves that their
ventures which was our name our name for
the fake pretend face vengeance
short-lived webseries oh you don't think
they wait for that phone call come on
internet waiting that that internet
phone call from the internet patron of
one by the way you guys I just
downloaded the screen junkies Plus app
I'm very excited great new content some
people are still are threatening
unsubscribe from that I have seen this
okay well there you go that's the that's
the thor ragnarok honest trailer look
when the guy from what we do in the
shadow says I'm gonna make a Thor movie
like Big Trouble in Little China I'm
gonna like that movie like this movie a
lot it's kind of in our wheelhouse
eighties vibe of like pre Star Wars
science fiction mm-hmm a lot of heavy
metal and jokes I mean come on yeah I
love I want to see his bubbles movie
which he's working yes motion bubbles
the chimp yeah movie yeah that's gonna
be awesome hundred percent into that and
hopefully comes back and does Thor for
for hopefully because more for Thor Thor
well hopefully uh hopefully we'll be
back next week hopefully we won't go
dark there was something that will
lighten yeah yeah spruce up the place
yeah yeah give it some sunshine yeah
we'll see dim but we don't we wanted to
be the opposite of that yeah
it's like you know we've done enough
yeah okay no one more it's like it's
like it's pretty it's a good idea but we
should stop them all right guys I will
see you next week for another thrilling
episode of honest trailer comes it to
Balrog
[Music]
you